In the wake of World War II, as the Cold War began,...
...the Korean Peninsula was divided along the 38th Parallel.
The North received Soviet backing while the United States supported the South.
In 1948, the two sides became officially known as the Democratic People's...
...Republic of Korea in the north and the Republic of Korea in the south.
The Korean War broke out on June the 25th 1950...
...when the North's army invaded the South.
Capturing Seoul within days, North Korean forces advanced to the tip of the Peninsula.
A UN coalition led by American troops stepped in to force the North Koreans back...
...pushing them as far as the Sino-Korean border.
Chinese forces crossed into the North to help launch a counteroffensive.
UN troops retaliated and eventually in May 1951,...
...the border between the two countries was fixed around the 38th Parallel.
In July 1953, North Korea signed a ceasefire agreement...
...with the US, marking the end of the fighting.
An estimated two to four million people died or disappeared during the conflict.
No formal peace treaty has since been signed...
...leaving North and South Korea still technically at war.